bonjour thomas porte merci de répondre à
nos questions sur arte france cette
déclaration sensiblement différente un
des propos d'emmanuel mâcon est ce
qu'elles révèlent une certaine fracture
au sein du couple exécutif croce
propositions extrêmement grave surtout
dans la période à laquelle on se trouve
vous avez remarqué le climat de tension
qui règne dans la société et ses propos
ils sont dangereux parce que si les
mêmes que ceux qui avaient utilisé
marine le pen à l'époque mais quand on
regarde un peu dans les détails on n'est
pas surpris puisque la plume aujourd'hui
de jean castex et celles qui étaient
déjà à l'heure où nicolas sarkozy donc
on a une droitisation du discours et
même plus en reprenant ces mots là on
reprend plus haut niveau de l'état les
les propos et les thèses de l'extrême
droite c'est extrêmement inquiétant
effectivement c à c à contre-courant de
ce qu'avait dit à l'époque emmanuel
macron sur la colonisation donc c'est
vraiment préoccupant d'avoir une telle
prise de position dans une période
avancer des idées comme ça ça faisait un
peu café du commerce c'était pas très
sérieux s'est jeté de l'huile sur le feu
une fois de plus alors qu'on a besoin
d'apaisement et de fraternité justement
vous parlez de contexte actuel un
contexte de tension qu'on connaît
évidemment mais cette nouvelle polémique
est ce que ce n'est pas finalement
rajouter de la polémique à la polémique
non c'est pas rajouter de la polémique à
la polémique on peut pas laisser passer
ce genre de déclaration surtout qu'un
élément du premier ministre du
gouvernement d' emmanuel macron qui
parle de la colonisation qui on n'aurait
pas se repentir est parce qu on devrait
être fier de ça alors qu'on sait les
ravages qui a causé la colonisation
les milliers de morts et tout ce que
cela engendre et derrière il ya eu des
discours extrêmement clair là dessus sur
l'état français depuis quelques années
et heureusement d'ailleurs sur les
responsabilités de l'état français sur
la question de la colonisation
je crois que dans cette période là comme
dans n'importe quelle période on ne peut
pas utiliser parler de la colonisation
comme vient de le faire jean castex est
totalement irresponsable
pourquoi la génération actuelle devrait
s'excuser d'un fait historique elle peut
observer avec critique mais pour autant
dont elle n'est pas responsable
il n'est pas question de s'excuser ou
pas il est question de regarder
l'histoire et de regarder la véracité
des faits et la responsabilité de l'état
français elle est assumée dans la
colonisation
elle est assumée dans les désastres
qu'elle a commis sur les territoires
l'été où elle occupe et d'économie c'est
aujourd'hui ça la réalité donc il n'est
pas question d'avancer la communisation
qui serait
l'argument selon lequel sa la
justification du terrorisme islamiste on
avait déjà entendu jeudi marine le pen
qui avait dit c'est l'argument utilisé
pour les jeunes dans les banlieues pour
se révolter
non il est pas il n'est pas question de
ça la responsabilité des gouvernements
elle est engagée sur la question de la
colonisation et on ne peut pas avoir
aujourd'hui de tels propos c'est nier ce
qui s'est passé et c'est vraiment jeter
de l'huile sur le feu je crois que c'est
vraiment pas à la hauteur de la
situation
on connaît aujourd'hui une période
extrêmement difficile avec plusieurs
attentats des personnes qui ont perdu la
vie on a besoin de réponses politiques
concrètes on n'a pas besoin d'un espèce
d'appel à l'unité nationale d'ailleurs
que les premiers membres du gouvernement
ont été ceux qui ont rendu l'unité
nationale à un accusant la gauche et les
écologistes d'être responsable de tout
ce qui se passait avec le fameux terme
islamo-gauchiste donc je crois que c'est
c'est vraiment pas sérieux et je crois
que jean castex doit aujourd'hui revenir
sur ce qu'il a dit et on attend une
prise de position qui soit vraiment plus
en adéquation avec la réalité de ce
qu'avait dit à l'époque emmanuel macron
et cette polémique et ce n'est pas fini
ce que cherchent les terroristes qu est
de faire naître une polémique comme
celle ci pourra diviser les français je
crois que vous avez raison sur une chose
c'est que le premier objectif des
terroristes c'est de diviser les
français de fracturer la société et de
faire croire que l'état de droit n'est
pas la solution n'est pas la meilleure
réponse à apporter on a vu depuis
plusieurs jours des élus de droite qui
sont montés au créneau pour réclamer à
guantanamo la française pour avoir une
déviation de guerre pour reprendre les
termes de marine le pen croit qu'il faut
dans cette période là la meilleure
réponse qu'on peut donner c'est une
réponse d'abord de fermeté à l'égard dès
terroristes islamistes pour les mettre
hors d'état de nuire ça c'est une
réalité mais après il faut rester
extrêmement soudée sur nos valeurs sûres
ce qui fait notre république et l'état
de droit est aujourd'hui la meilleure
réponse qu'on peut apporter à ces gens
là et il faut absolument pas reculer sur
toutes nos valeurs parce que là on leur
donnerait quelque part et quand il
aurait gagné si ont reculé sur ce qui
fonde notre démocratie
et comment expliquer cette détestation
de la france souligné par jean castex je
sais pas si aujourd'hui une détestation
de la france et moi je là je la perçois
pas comme ça on a des mouvements qui
exprime effectivement une roger de ce
qu'est la france mais je considère et
aujourd'hui on est nombreux à le penser
que 99,9 pour cent des musulmans qui
vivent sur le territoire français
adorent la france
vivre avec leur religion dans le cadre
privé comme les autres religions n'y a
pas de ya pas de détestation majeur de
la france fait aujourd'hui des problèmes
qui dépassent largement le cadre
national il faudrait aussi parler des
questions géopolitiques ou le rôle de la
france est engagée depuis des années
ça apporte des réponses je redis
vraiment politique d'ampleur et pas des
petites phrases prononcées au journal de
20 heures pour essayer un peu de voilà
de buzz et sur l'actualité tout le monde
a bien compris que c'était extrêmement
dangereux et ça s'inscrit en plus à la
veille d'une rentrée scolaire très
préoccupant où on a vu ça devait être
une journée de mémoire et donnèrent à
samuel paty et les décisions du ministre
blogueurs ont été ont suscité la colère
à juste titre des enseignants donc on a
besoin de retrouver de la sérénité dans
ce pays
on a besoin de retrouver de la
fraternité on a besoin de de poser les
bases d'une société mais aussi patrice
qui est à mon avis sera la seule réponse
possible aux manières de chaque jour ce
qui fait mal à notre pays à savoir le
terrorisme
merci thomas porte d'abord répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
syndicaliste cgt membre du pcf et auteur
du livre au coeur de la haine aux
éditions arcane17